let's go through this report um i think
the best way probably to do it is let's
just go uh graphic by graphic and then
we can kind of talk about what uh what
each one of them is uh is describing
um the the first one is this penetration
of the target market
uh and it also has an overlay of time so
help everyone understand how you guys
think about this
sure we can first start with just you
know what is a technological adoption
curve so
with all technologies they kind of move
through these phases in the graphic here
we have them labeled as innovators early
adopters early majority late majority
and laggards and so each kind of subset
has a different amount of conviction
and you know you'd say some of the the
early innovators are perhaps much more
forward thinking uh more willing to take
risk etc
and that allows them to reap great
reward as the technology moves into the
later stages of the adoption curve
one thing to note amongst you know this
this kind of takes place for all major
technologies this s-curve of adoption
once these curves pass that 10 threshold
that's where you see really the most
aggressive growth and as we'll get to in
a moment uh where we think bitcoin
adoption is i think we're uh getting
ready to hit that kind of main s-curve
of adoption but we still are in that
early adopters phase uh but before we
move on to to that uh we'll continue
with some of these other historical
technological adoption curves
that makes uh makes complete sense and
obviously i think each one of these
cohorts of people uh ends up spreading
the word to the next right the early
adopters basically tell the early
majority and you kind of continue to
spread it uh and then obviously another
piece of this that i think usually goes
unspoken up is like money is the most
viral product in the world and so
naturally people are sending it to each
other they're receiving it from each
other and ends up driving like this
network effect um you've got another uh
chart here from from blockwear that says
technology adoption curves and you've
overlaid a ton of other technology uh
and their adoption curves what is this
showing us
yeah so something to think about here is
like bitcoin is growing on the rails of
the internet so it's gonna grow faster
than the internet which is spread on
analog rails and mostly word of mouth
but basically these the big blue and
pink lines is a weighted adoption curve
of all the other past technology
adoptions and that's what we use to
apply to forecast the future adoption of
bitcoin
got it and so when you look at something
like this like i think it is uh the
landline maybe it's the green line the
one that's kind of taken the longest to
go there is that mainly uh it took a
longer time because it was one of the
earlier technologies and then as each
one of these technologies gets built
like you mentioned bitcoin is being
built on top of the internet we should
expect these adoption curves to actually
accelerate
i think i think that's correct and as
you just alluded to you know when we
look at
like the landline
at the lower end of the spectrum versus
we look at excuse me like the the
smartphone
uh or social media or up on kind of the
upper echelon of these adoption curves i
don't think that's by coincidence
whatsoever and the reason is kind of
what you just alluded to that
you basically have before the internet
technology spreading on these analog
rails very similar to like a dirt path
versus spreading on the internet what is
which is analogous to like a super
highway of of adoption spreading and so
with that you know with bitcoin very
similar to like social media it can
spread much quicker because the rails
that it's spreading on are much faster
let alone all of the kind of monetary
incentives that we all know very well
but you know i think in this report we
tried to focus on
rather than convincing you what the what
the value proposition of bitcoin is
obviously there's there's several
including bitcoin being the ultimate
bearer asset uh you know bitcoin
scarcity it's decentralized nature
censorship resistance uh you know all
these different things that that we talk
about uh you know the inevitability of
you know more debt expansion in the fiat
system
all these things that we talk about of
what makes bitcoin valuable we decided
to exclude from this report because we
think there's been a lot of work that's
eloquently been put together on
describing what the bullish case for
bitcoin is uh and so with that in mind
we really focus on this report of
justice the the monetary network effects
uh adoption network effects that we
believe bitcoin has
in context of why why people are
adopting it so instead of looking at i
guess the way to frame it would be why
are people adopting bitcoin we're more
looking at the rate of which they are
adopting bitcoin and comparing that to
traditional uh network effects because
bitcoin at the end of the day uh is a
growing monetary technology and so yeah
again uh kind of long-winded answer here
but i i think it's paired with social
media in the basket of it's growing on
the rails of the internet i would make
an argument that it's growing even
faster because the monetary incentives
of kind of the economic background
backdrop of what's going to unfold over
the next 5 10 15 years
but even out of out of that context just
just saying that it's growing on the uh
on the rails of the internet means that
it should be growing in that kind of
upper at least 10 percent uh 10th
percentile of all these other
technological adoption curves that we
see here makes complete sense and then
we've got the bitcoin uh user data
specifically cumulative sum of new
entities what is this showing us
sure i could take this one uh so
for for this report we decided to go
with uh on-chain data for a few reasons
one of which is just kind of our bread
and butter
and one of the forms of analysis that we
feel most comfortable with
the other one is we feel like this is
the best way to get hard data on the
user adoption
you could do things like
look at you know exchange user estimates
um you know there's there's some public
company such as coinbase who discloses
their user data but then we have other
private companies that don't have to
disclose their user data and we felt
that by looking at the number of unique
wallets that was the best way to have
hard data on what the user adoption
growth looks like
with that being said though this does
likely underestimate the actual value by
a fair amount and the reason is because
one wallet or one unique cluster of
entities that we're looking at here in
this graph could actually be a custodian
or an exchange now with that being said
though
we do we do want to just disclose that
nuance but with that being said we do
feel like the number of unique wallets
at this time is still a very good proxy
for the number of users and a good
conservative estimate as to how many
users are
are or have been on the network so in
this chart we're looking at uh new
entities so new entities is solely
telling you the cumulative sum of all
the unique entities that have ever been
on the network uh and as you can see
that's just over 253 million users that
have ever been on the network and so the
reason i'm emphasizing that word is
because then when we next when we get to
the next chart
which is net entities growth or entities
net growth i should say
this is instead looking at the number of
entities that are on the network now
and so a bit of a distinguish between
the two
because the former is looking at how
many have ever been on the network this
metric is taking into account the
entities that have left the network and
therefore is telling you how many are
active how many are on the network today
uh and according to on chain data we
estimate that's about 30.8 million
unique entities and for our sake of the
report we're using this as our users
metric um and again that we feel like
this is a good proxy for the number
of uh of users of the network
although it likely underestimates the
value if you if you are including you
know exchange users or users of
custodians uh and in the future
the uh
our view on this being a a
a good enough proxy for that for that
user number the real user number uh
we'll go down because we think over time
less people will interact with the base
chain but we do feel like the uh the
kind of
the validity of this as a proxy for the
number of people that are using bitcoin
is still very strong yeah i mean look it
makes sense to me and uh your point
about more and more users will start to
use uh the lightning network or other
layer two side chains etc uh may change
the base chain uh but but still there's
a very clear trend here uh that user
adoption is increasing and these
measurements are probably the best that
we have to to identify that uh you guys
included a data point that i uh was
actually i've never seen anyone uh go
ahead and take a look at it's that point
three six percent of the global
population are users of the bitcoin
monetary network today walk us through
this one
yeah this is simply taking that
cumulative sum of entities net growth
and then dividing it by the global
population which is about 8 billion
users and i honestly i expected this to
be higher i expected you know global
adoption around two to five percent
somewhere in that range but still being
less than one percent is is incredibly
bullish we already have you know el
salvador as a nation state adopting
bitcoin and we've got michael taylor
putting in billions of dollars and we're
not even at one percent adoption yet
yeah and then we've got this like
percent of global population uh and you
try to actually forecast using the old
adoption cycles or the historic adoption
cycles uh when i see something like this
i mean it is pretty crazy to think about
uh if this is accurate which i think you
guys are saying hey look there's a
forecast here again could be inaccurate
it's really hard to kind of assign these
uh these adoption curves uh but if only
point three six percent of the global
population is actually on the bitcoin
network uh as a monetary network there's
a lot of people left to get on right
like like what how did you guys kind of
come up with this uh this chart here
yeah so uh with the the past data it
wasn't until um around 10
uh adoption that we had most of the data
so up until 10 we're using the
compounded annual growth rate of that
cumulative sum of entities net growth
and then from there we applied the past
adoption curves and like for the reasons
we laid out before bitcoin we we kind of
expect to grow faster because of all
the it's just growing on the rails of
the internet the speed of information
and there's the direct financial
incentive to adopt like you can see the
benefit of early adoption like nominally
for example if you if you're an early
adopter of like the car or the internet
you might have some increase in your
efficiency and that's going to help you
out financially but you don't see an
actual number like i bought bitcoin at x
dollars and i have gained 100x in in
value just by being an early adopter
like that that mental framework of like
you can see how much you're benefiting
financially is gonna encourage more
people to adopt it faster
got it and then the last graphic that we
have here uh will you tweet out and said
this is the ultimate bullish case for
bitcoin and one simple visual
exponentially growing user growth
juxtaposed with bitcoins pre-programmed
increasingly deflationary monetary
policy and you've overlaid those two
here uh describe it like kind of how you
think about these two things and their
relationship to each other
yeah for sure so again this this green
line is as mitch just said we use the
keger up until that ten percent
threshold where we have the data for all
the historical adoption curves we then
applied that historical data for the
adoption curves that we have to
bitcoin's uh future projections of what
we think uh we'll see the user growth
add and that's that that green line
and then in in the yellow
we have the supply issuance and of
course that's pre-programmed and is
already set in stone so we do know
exactly
what the supply issuance will be for
sure um and so when you when you plot
these two and kind of juxtapose the two
you get this really beautiful graphic in
my opinion which is kind of a visual for
the ultimate bullish case for btc and as
you can see we have you know
an exponential amount of new users that
will come in over the next several
decades and we still are in very early
days and as we believe as we mentioned
we believe earlier in in the segment uh
we think we've yet to hit that real
s-curve of adoption uh and then you pair
that with bitcoin's uh supply issuance
becoming incl increasingly uh
deflationary which means you know if you
if you combine the two over a long term
it it kind of builds the perfect recipe
for for number co-op over over the long
term and so uh with that being said i
think this is a very simple graphic for
kind of
illustrating the high-level bullish case
for for a long-term bitcoin investor
when you think about the inflection
point of users there are there specific
things that you all are looking for that
you think can drive it or is it just a
matter of time and allowing a network
effect to kind of do what network
effects do and uh spread globally
i i think number go up is the biggest uh
factor there and that's personally what
brought me into bitcoin like last
late 2020 i saw it going up i'm like
what is this and i think a certain
amount of people who who find out about
bitcoin actually do the due diligence
and figure out like the technicals you
can go beyond just the price chart i
think a lot of people just look at the
price chart of bitcoin they don't they
don't dig in and anybody who digs in
they they become a full like
full-fledged bitcoiner like michael
saylor says there's no informed
critiques
so i think it's sort of like does the
price going up lead adoption or does
adoption lead price and i think i think
it's uh price leads adoption because
even if nobody else was to adopt bitcoin
due to the increasing scarcity of the
havings like every four years the
marginal cost of production is gonna
double and even if it's just you you me
and will buying all the bitcoin it's
gonna force the price up because i want
all the bitcoin you guys want all the
bitcoin
so the price will go up and then
adoption's going to follow
yeah it is uh this thing where price
ends up in the marketing department you
have a decentralized entity uh how does
price going down affect that does that
push people out and kind of churn users
or what have you all seen there with the
relationship between user growth and
like the actual downward price given
that the assets volatile
i think what's interesting i mean you
can go back if you go back up to this
entities net growth chart not the
cumulative sum but the one before that
uh this will illustrate what you're what
you're talking about and as you can see
like obviously in in bull markets that's
as much alluded to kind of the ultimate
marketing campaign for btc and when the
price is going up um it's it's the chart
before this one not the cumulative sum
just the the raw value um
as you can see like in the bull market
you have more users coming on but in the
bear that that number does decline
although the cumulative value does go up
and that's just because you know retail
investors new market participants
kind of lose interest lose conviction
and you get a supply concentration back
to those who are highly convicted in the
asset class
but you know i think over the long term
the trend is clear that you have a
growing number of of new users although
you know kind of based on bitcoin's
cyclicality the rate of which that that
that's increasing kind of kind of
fluctuates a bit
yeah and then when you guys think about
mining as a part of this
obviously hash rate has continued to
increase uh coming out of the china ban
uh it's the strongest computer network
in the world
there's some geopolitical
kind of shifting that's going on you
know some people are very receptive some
people are more abrasive
but pretty much the trend is up and to
the right when it comes to hash rate is
that what you would expect uh user
growth and hash rate to move in tandem
so if all of a sudden we saw hash rate
drop we would see users drop or vice
versa users drop hash rate would drop or
is it you know uh not as correlated as
maybe people may think just looking at
it
i think it's kind of like a
chicken or the egg type of type of
question of it
because you know i think i think
the price going up draws in the
incentive for new people to come on and
mine btc uh you do tend to see kind of
this lag where
after the bull run that's when because
there's a lag between when people order
machines versus when they actually can
get plugged in so you tend to see this
lag of hash rate coming on after the
major price move that's just kind of how
it's gone throughout bitcoin's history
uh so i would say i think they're all
correlated as to your point i think you
know uh the price increasing it goes in
tandem with uh with with the adoption
although you know i think it's difficult
to assign a certain value of price per
user and this is something we had kind
of flirted with doing and we're going to
do a part two where we're kind of
applying this information to a price
model uh we decided to just leave it
with solely the the user data
and you know the issue with that is you
can do like a
a very long term kind of mean
but you know you could have like a you
know the saudi prince could throw in a
couple yards tomorrow and that's going
to increase the price but doesn't
necessarily mean that there's more users
coming on the network
but i do think overall over a long-term
kind of outlook that
those two things are very much
correlated and then ask the price
increases that draws on hash so i would
just say it's kind of like a you know
does the chicken come before the egg
type of type of question and that you
know i do think they're all they're all
correlated though it's just hard to say
you know which one which one is causing
the other when they're all kind of uh
you know
causation of of the other so
uh i i think um
you know i i think back to your question
about like kind of the catalyst
i think it's difficult to to say exactly
like what the catalyst for btc will be i
think there's a lot of kind of theorized
catalyst for for that kind of main
s-curve of adoption
but i do think the trend is clear is
that you've got this network effect that
continues chucking along and growing
exponentially and then at some point
that's going to continue pressing up and
up and up and then at some point you're
going to have some type of event that
just releases that valve up and you're
going to see that adoption just kind of
reach
escape velocity i kind of think of every
time we have one of these cycles and a
the price increasing as well as adoption
uh you know increasing in tandem with
that you're kind of knocking on the
ceiling and every time we come closer
and closer to reaching that escape
velocity uh but you know finally
eventually we're going to push through
and that's when we'll reach that kind of
main s-curve of adoption maybe that's
something breaking down in um you know
the current fiat system or some type of
geopolitical event that has people
flocked to btc as a safe haven which
we didn't see earlier this year which
was a bit unfortunate with kind of the
russia ukraine situation i think a lot
of bitcoiners would have liked to see uh
bitcoin be used as a geopolitical hedge
more broadly but uh you know i think i
think one of those type of events could
could lead to that s-curve but i think
kind of the high-level takeaway is you
know there's there's a risk to owning
btc through volatility um and you know
you can you know investing one-on-one is
you just adjust for volatility with
position sizing if you're uncomfortable
with bitcoin's volatility you just make
it a smaller portion of your portfolio
but i also think there's a risk to not
owning bitcoin because i think when you
look at this uh kind of adoption
projection that we have
one of one of the biggest takeaways that
i would say is that whenever this does
happen
uh it it will happen quickly uh it'll
happen in likely a matter of kind of
five or ten years where you'll see that
huge gap in
increase in jump and adoption and so i
would say you know get off zero and if
anything this kind of illustrates the
the fact that there's a risk to not
owning bitcoin in the same sense that
there's a risk to owning bitcoin uh
through volatility
makes
to piggyback on that real quick like as
far as catalyst it's i would think it's
definitely some kind of break in the
fiat system or some some event similar
to canada or russia this past year and
the optimistic view is that something
happens like that and people realize
like bitcoin is the only thing you can
truly own that can't be diluted and they
flock to that but then there's also the
pessimist pessimistic view that when
when the fiat system breaks they will
roll out the central bank digital
currencies and people will sort of flock
to that instead of realizing like
bitcoin is is the best option
so we've got some questions from the
audience here and i'll just kind of
rapid fire shoot them at you guys and
and let me know what you think somebody
said how can you classify a unique user
as getting off the network would these
just be dormant wallets or would it be
wallets with zero bitcoin in them
yeah um so yeah exactly so they're
wallets that have been zeroed out and
that haven't been used in x amount of
time um it's i don't know
the threshold for the amount of dormancy
off the top of my head it's in the
report
but there's a certain time threshold for
how long a wallet isn't active and then
paired with the fact that it's just
zeroed out and then they say okay well
that that that entity has been deemed
dormant got it uh and somebody else said
won't billionaires or others uh conduct
speculative attacks uh on bitcoin and
then try to buy bitcoin at cheaper
prices
i'm not selling them my bitcoin so
that's not really going to work and uh
it doesn't like they can do all the
attacks they want they can try and buy
and sell and manipulate the market but
they can't change the protocol they
can't change 21 million they can't
change the difficulty adjustment they
can't change the having so
they really that it's a moot point in my
opinion
somebody said any concern about miners
losing profitability as time goes on
patrick ford asked that
um i mean
in the in the short term you are
starting to see like miners margins get
compressed a bit and you are starting to
see some selling uh both in the public
market from some public miners including
like riot and then also in on chain we
can see that some of the the miners have
been selling lately as their their
margins get compressed but that's a
pretty kind of typical uh bitcoin bear
market kind of dynamic that that's
played out and you saw miners were kind
of the capitulation bottom that was put
in in 2018 and i'm not necessarily
saying that miners will be be forming
the bottom but you are seeing that
dynamic a bit uh playing out you saw the
hash ribbons cross recently which kind
of indicates that hash has been coming
off a bit um and this is when the 30-day
moving average crosses below the the
60-day moving average of hash and then
you've also started to see again that
that minor net position change metric
showing that the net change the 30-day
change in this minor balance is dropping
a bit which perhaps
indicates that you know their their
margins are getting compressed a bit
they're having to shave off some of
their bitcoin holdings to cover that
max l asked nothing bad had to happen
like increasing mistrust in government
etc for cell phones with the internet to
be useful is bitcoin's accelerated
adoption dependent on bad things
happening
i don't think so and that's a very good
point and that's what i was kind of
saying like i think the adoption curve
over time is kind of just this natural
uh technological adoption because
bitcoin is just an amazing technology
it's a kind of zero to one invention in
my opinion so i think you just have this
natural technological growth but at the
same time it's it's built for bad events
to happen in that sense in the framework
that the question is is said so
i would say i think you have this
natural network effect that chucks along
and then eventually if we do have some
type of event that could potentially be
a catalyst in that sense it would send
bitcoin into that you know hyper growth
s-curve phase um but i do think
regardless bitcoin just as a technology
will continue chucking along its
exponential growth regardless
uh somebody asked what price are you all
backing up the truck for bitcoin
basically how do you guys think about
current price action and are there
certain things you're looking at there
oh man i would say uh check out our our
segment pump and i did the last two
weeks we talked about that a lot um
i mean look i think uh you know kind of
piggyback on a lot of things we've been
saying like
bitcoin is in the kind of the lower 10
to 15 percentile for all historical
valuation metrics i think this is a
great time to dollar cost average into
bitcoin heavily
is it the pico bottom
i i don't know if you could you could
necessarily say that given you know some
of these metrics aren't at these full
reset levels that will reach kind of
reset between 20 to 24k uh but i think
you the question you have to ask
yourself is you know over the long term
if you think bitcoin's gonna you know do
what we think it's gonna do uh does it
make a difference buying between you
know 24k and and you know 25 to 30k
perhaps the answer is no
i'm a bit greedy and i try to
strategically allocate so i'm waiting
for you know kind of getting below
realized price and some of the other you
know indicators that we talked about on
the show uh but i i do think broadly you
know if i'm talking to my parents or
whoever it may be comes up to me on the
street you know i would say you know
it's
we're kind of in the one of the lowest
regimes of evaluation for btc in its
history uh and with that you should be
allocating more heavily in your dollar
cost averaging strategy if that's what
you're looking to do
makes sense somebody said uh inflation's
just transitory is the name on youtube
said uh will bitcoin d peg from the
dollar and it will look for daily users
basically at some point will we not
price bitcoin in dollars uh and people
will just talk about it you know in
terms of satoshis or bitcoin or do you
think there'd always be a dollar
exchange price attached to it
as long as the dollar exists there
probably will be some kind of exchange
but i think more people are going to
shift to pricing things in satoshi's i
know i already do i know you already do
pomp well i'm assuming you do i think as
more people realize that bitcoin is the
ultimate asset they're going to start
viewing like
charts like real estate and equities in
bitcoin and perhaps they're still still
will be an exchange rate to the dollar
if the dollar's around but most people
will use bitcoin as their measuring
stick because it can't move one
bitcoin's always one bitcoin and also
like if you're not consciously looking
at something and saying this is x value
of sats you're also kind of
subconsciously doing it just by
realizing there's like opportunity cost
so if you're saying hey maybe i'm going
to hold back on buying this because i'd
rather buy bitcoin although you're not
necessarily saying like this is worth x
number of satoshis subconsciously you're
saying that you think bitcoin is more
valuable than that therefore you're like
kind of indirectly you know pricing
things in in btc but i think as as mitch
alluded to as as more people
uh do that you know it'll kind of become
this organic thing that people price
things in btc i think we're very far
from from not pricing things in dollars
including bitcoin but ultimately as does
the corner say you know one btc is one
btc
lisa canteros says a quick question for
will or mitch non-technical question but
how do you continue to help those around
you understand the importance of bitcoin
most of my peers and even my kids think
i am crazy for talking about bitcoin
i wish i had the answer to that question
i i try really hard myself i mean the
best you can do is just sort of like
hammer them i suppose but like at some
point you just gotta back off because
like people they're gonna go to it on
their own if they're curious like i
think at this point it's so it's viewed
as such a risky asset for some reason
and it takes a certain level of
intellectual curiosity to to dig in like
to in my opinion it only takes two three
hours of research to to fall down the
rabbit hole and once you do like there's
there's no going back like once you
realize the technical aspects of bitcoin
i think something uh that that's a
really good resource is safety the fiat
standard comparing the fiat system to as
if it were like a [ __ ] coin i think
that's a really good analogy just
pointing at how broken the traditional
fiat system is is in my opinion the best
way to get people to to see bitcoin is
the answer i think that's right i think
um you know looking at what the problem
is versus the solution i think as
bitcoiners oftentimes you come up to
somebody
at a party or whatever and and uh you're
like hey look bitcoin is the greatest
thing ever it's scarce it's
decentralized whatever people are like
okay that's awesome but like why do i
need this right and so like i think
it's more important to to orangeville
people to focus on the problem versus
the solution because they're not going
to understand the problem that the
solution is solving if you don't do that
um and and look i think at the end of
the day you can only do what you can do
right and i think like uh some
bitcoiners feel this sense of like you
know they're like noah trying to get
people on knows ark but you know at the
same time it's like people are going to
buy into btc at the price that they
deserve and although you should help
everybody around you you know i think to
some extent like you can only do what
you could do you don't want to you don't
want to annoy everybody in your circle
right i think you kind of you kind of uh
gently chill to not overwhelm people i
think if you start just like you know
going overboard just like talking their
head off they're gonna be like okay well
like this is like overwhelming and i
just you know just dude like leave me
alone
i think you to i think you want to like
gently kind of just you know talk
through it a bit uh explain explain the
the the problem instead of the solution
and then kind of let them like come to
the the conclusion on on their own as
you kind of gently gently shell
so the last question uh comes from awok
says any concerns on the centralization
of minors to larger public entities or
too much of hash being in the united
states
sure i mean i think that that's a valid
long-term concern in terms of hash
coming to the united states um i you
know i don't think in the same way that
people were worried about china i think
the us
from like uh you know although i don't
agree with like all the esg fud but i do
think like the us amongst uh other you
know other regions around the world are
going to practice higher kind of uh
integrity around energy usage and just
regulation in general and and so i think
you'll have much more transparency on
that side so i think that's a good thing
but long term of course we do want to
see hash rate get uh you know
decentralized across the world we don't
want to see the majority come to the
united states even though at block where
we do personally see that as the best
place to mine bitcoin um but you know
over the long term i think you'll you'll
see you know
natural incentives come up from from
nations that adopt bitcoin including el
salvador as kind of one of the first
dominoes and and with that you'll start
to see hash migrate to those places as
well uh especially some of those those
energy those countries that have uh
cheaper energy and to add on to that
that's this is why america is a really
great place because we have 50 different
states if new york wants to shoot
themselves in the foot and not allow
bitcoin mining okay texas tennessee
kentucky pennsylvania they're gonna be
like all right come here like we want
that business we want that capital so 50
different states that like you saw it
with legalized marijuana like some
people just say or some states just say
no to that the federal government they
do what they want to do and i think
that's a really great thing as long as
the states have sovereignty i don't
think we have to worry about over
centralizing in the united states but of
course like my bitcoin globally that
that's the best option of course but uh
the united states is a great place just
because the political stability and the
power
yeah it's um it's crazy that we're uh
that we're living through this it could
be uh you know once in a millennium type
uh
situation so i appreciate you two uh
doing so much great work on this uh the
report looks awesome i'm gonna dig into
it this afternoon where can we send
people to uh follow you both on the
internet and also to uh download the
report so they can read it for
themselves
mitch you wanna go first oh yeah you can
follow me on twitter at mitchellhottle
hodl but uh also follow the blockware
team account at blockwhere team that's
where uh the best bitcoin one-liners
come from
and uh the report i believe it was
emailed out with the the newsletter so
if you subscribe to the newsletter you
can uh get the report
well that's true thank you yeah thanks
so much for having us on pump this was
awesome they're showing us kind of get a
you know a little little pr boost after
after releasing it this morning so uh
you know it's a pleasure talking to you
as always if anyone wants to see the
report i tweeted it out about an hour
ago you can also go to
blackroadintelligence.com and find the
report there whether you're subscribed
to the newsletter or not but of course
i'm going to say the subscribe but if
you don't feel like you know subscribing
you can still check out the uh the
newsletter through through the website
link but
i i appreciate it everyone please go
subscribe go follow these two
uh
moist
going from the youtube comments to now
mitch at blockwear man i'm i'm so proud
of you i'm so proud of you this is this
is
without you paul thank you well i i mean
i just [ __ ] on the internet so i
don't know if i could you bet your
course you know that's that's how i
found out about the job and uh it worked
out it worked out it's perfect so all
right fellas i appreciate both of you
we'll definitely do this again in the
future uh and until then enjoy it and
let's see what uh let's see what happens
over the next couple weeks
thanks so much